Je crois que nous avons le choix dans ce monde
sur la façon de raconter des histoires tristes d'une
part, vous pouvez édulcorer
rien n'est trop foiré qui ne peut être
réparé avec vous Peter Gabriel chanson J'aime
cette version autant que la prochaine
fille  ce n'est tout simplement pas la vérité c'est la
vérité hé faites-vous des amis
désolé pas mal je suis Augustus waters je
suis en rémission depuis environ un an et
demi peut-être que vous aimeriez partager certaines de
vos peurs avec le groupe Cheers
oubli  quel est ton nom
noisette quel est ton nom complet noisette grâce
Lancaster
pourquoi tourne-toi vers moi est-il beau alors quelle est
ton histoire
qui a diagnostiqué mr.  joie ouais ta vraie
histoire je suis assez inattendu qu'à la
main tu sais que Gus parle de toi tout
le temps nous ne sommes que des amis j'espère que
tu réalises que tu essaies de garder tes
distances avec moi ne diminue en rien mon
affection pour toi Gus  Je suis une grenade un
jour je vais exploser et je vais
tout anéantir dans mon sillage
Je ne veux pas te blesser tu ne peux
pas choisir si tu te blesses dans ce monde
mais tu as un  dis dans qui te blesse je
suis amoureux de toi grâce noisette et je
sais que l'amour n'est qu'un cri dans le
vide et que l'oubli est inévitable
et je suis amoureux de toi tous
tes efforts pour m'empêcher d'échouer
nous sommes un  désordre chaud
es-tu en colère si en colère que tu as besoin de casser
quelque chose dont
tu as besoin de moi pour toujours dans les
jours comptés et je ne peux pas te dire comment
ils t'appellent pour notre petit infini
c'est une bonne vie noisette grâce d'accord d'
accord
toi